if she sees you as a beta she's always
going to see you as a beta and the idea
of like the work you have to put in to
get out of that frame versus just
starting over can you talk about that
yeah
um a lot of guys will you know again you
know she touches his pee pee he gets
into a long-term relationship married
girlfriend whatever
um if it if you go through the process
of of betaization through a thousand
concessions which isn't a question of if
you're going to go through it it's just
to what extent okay because women will
[__] test guys and if you yield then you
will start going through the process not
not everybody gets beta ties though
right like some guys will push back even
me the guy that wrote the book that
makes the videos that has half a billion
views on YouTube even I have to check
myself sometimes to make sure that she's
in my frame sort of thing so sorry back
to the original question Mike the
original question was it had to do with
Holland am I am I losing my [__] I
forgot what were we talking about here
oh uh the um oh she sees you as a beta
she'll obviously you as a beta yeah like
so so the I because I agree with you
yeah when she sees you there then you're
kind of screwed right like once she
basically sees you as a beta male yeah
she doesn't look up to you yeah she gets
up in the morning morning she's
disgusted by you she doesn't want to
sleep with you she'll cry after sex you
know for example I've heard stories like
this bro
um you're kind of screwed it's it's very
very very difficult to fix that there's
a lot of like subreddits out there and
like men's coaches and like masculinity
coaches that will try to convince you
that you can fix it and you can just you
know lean into God or you can lead in
your masculinity and grow a beard and
you know drink you know darker beer sort
of thing and that'll fix it all but for
the most part when she sees you as a
beta she's always going to see you as a
beta I mean it's it's easier to
construct a brand new relationship than
it is to fix an old broken one right you
guys hear that grow beard and drink
darker beer man she'll come running back
so here's the thing you said before
about a scarcity mindset and you talked
about
um uh people having a victim mentality
right uh rule number three and Men of
action is abundance is always the answer
unless you have a heroin addiction but
abundance is always the answer so when
guys ask me I want to get over my ex I'm
like you need to see more women when
guys ask me I want to get my ex back the
answer is you need to see more women
when guys ask I want to get better at
dating the answer is you need to see
more women when guys ask me like what
should I do in order to get better at
reading I was like well you need to read
more books you know by people by mentors
that people that you look up to I want
to get better at business you need to
read more books by people you know
mentors you want to look up to what do I
do in order to
um you know get better with my fitness
you need to hang out with more people
who are in the shape that you want to be
in what do I do when I want to get
better with my business you need to find
more entrepreneurs that have the
business that you already want the
answer is always abundance the answer to
get over your problem or to to get rid
of the problem is always the same answer
right the answer is more and better and
so that's why I say when when you were
talking before about how do I fix this
relationship find out like there's
probably a lot of guys right now who are
watching this who like think about a
relationship that they're trying to fix
if you set boundaries around yourself
and actually started dating other women
you're also going to get this DM where
you at what are you doing from her out
of nowhere and how do is this goes back
to a previous thing we talked about how
do we show that we actually show it on
social media this is one of the other
things why I think social media is so
important is because when I do level up
I don't want to brag about it but there
needs to be some passive way for me to
show it and when you do that it's
incredible because of the scalability of
it how much you can you can show when it
comes to something like that so I agree
with you like don't try to fix those of
those other relationships go off to
other ones and you'll be shocked at how
many of them like come right back right
back for you
yeah you'll be surprised the amount of
steps that they want you to take to try
to fix a broken relationship I mean look
I get it if you got small kids and
you're and you're married and you've got
your not tied up you know with a life of
another person sort of thing and you
don't want to lose access to your kids
you don't want to lose access here you
know your financial resources you want
to give it the good college try some
guys might might fix it
um but I think you know for the most
part you know like we said earlier once
a woman sees you as weak and confident
basically as a soy boy beta male you're
gonna have a hard time fixing that and
to be honest with you you know for the
most part most guys don't have the
gumption to fix it if they're still in
that relationship yes they still have
her around it's only when they lose her
completely and they hit rock bottom and
Chaos ensues and it's like oh well she
left me for Steve from accounting like
why did that happen sort of thing then
they start going looking for answers on
the Internet or on YouTube and they find
something like a clip that I said
something
um that's when they start like that's
when it hits them yeah sort of thing and
then they're willing to really do the
work but you know for the most part A
lot of these guys you know once they've
been beta ties and she's and she's
literally disgusted by him like she
doesn't even want to touch him sort of
thing they don't know what to do they
they'll they'll go and get some stupid
book like the five love languages and
they have to give her words of
affirmation or some [__] like that
and that book's been disproven by the
way a hundred ways oh my God it was have
you seen the meme it was like at some
point women men need to to decide
whether or not they want to call out
women for astrology or get laid have you
ever seen that Meme that's hilarious you
know you can go to your energy crystals
and your astrological signs but it's not
going to work man oh she needs to look
up to you she needs she needs to be
excited by you yeah yeah beautiful I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out